innanzitutto buonasera
oggi viviamo in un momento di alta
complessità in cui piccole variabili
possono determinare grandi cambiamenti
in cui è impossibile capire cosa verrà
dopo cosa succederà siamo immersi in una
grandissima quantità di dati però
accedere alle informazioni accedere alle
persone è facile accedere alle
informazioni sulle persone su di noi si
aprono tantissime finestre finestre che
passano da twitter da facebook
dalle fotografie che postiamo dal nostro
profilo dai video e le persone senza
farsi un'idea di nuovi un'idea di noi
che viene prima di noi stessi
quest'idea porta gli altri a
coinvolgerci in alcuni progetti o non
coinvolgerci a invitarci alcuni eventi e
altro e allora noi professionisti come
possiamo rispondere a tutto questo la
chiave l'autenticità l'essere veri
basare la nostra reputazione su quello
che veramente facciamo sul valore che
creiamo sulle nostre reali capacità
la reputazione e l'identità sono
diventati ormai degli asset chiave di
cui non possiamo fare a meno
la reputazione però di cui parlo è un
tipo di reputazione che incubo un proges
l'organizzazione di cui faccio parte
definiamo reputazione operativa cioè
quella reputazione basata proprio sul
valore concreto che andiamo a realizzare
sulle nostre reali capacità sul
contributo che diamo alla nostra
comunità
se riusciamo a fare questo diverremo
centro di una rete
saremo riconosciuti per questo diverremo
autorevoli diverremo un punto di
riferimento
se riusciamo a costruire la nostra
reputazione operativa riusciremo anche
ad attrarre ciò che ci serve
oggi dovremmo ad accedere no per
evolvere per crescere ha tantissimo
materiale perché le cose vanno
velocissime e dovremo leggere tantissimi
articoli video eventi
non si può fare tutto e allora bisogna
attrarre quello di cui abbiamo bisogno e
anche a trarre quello che non sappiamo
neanche che ne abbiamo bisogno
l'attrazione non è qualcosa che capita
e sempre il frutto di qualcosa che
consapevolmente o inconsapevolmente
abbiamo determinato
e allora se il nostro collega il nostro
amico ci manda quell'articolo che
proprio riguardava quello che stiamo
studiando se veniamo invitati proprio a
quell'evento
non è un caso le persone in questo
contesto diventano fondamentali
proprio le persone perché noi da loro
impariamo queste persone ci danno
feedback
condividiamo le esperienze condividiamo
gli errori ci fanno da specchio ci
aprono ad altre persone diventano dei
nodi proprio su tutto questo abbiamo
sviluppato uno strumento che si chiama
core square cioè cuore al quadrato
si chiama così perché vedete lì i
quadranti i quadranti sono le iniziali
dei quadranti sono co di competences
competenze tre relazioni e di nuovo
contribution co resonance risonanza è
uno strumento interattivo che ci aiuta
proprio a sviluppare la regolazione
operativa a crescere ci aiuta a evolvere
a livello di come professionisti arriva
lo è la nostra professione e del vostro
mentite nativo quindi si parte da
competenze poi lavoriamo sulle nostre
relazioni sul contributo che diamo alla
nostra comunità di riferimento
facciamo lavoriamo sulla risonanza e
ritorniamo sulle nostre competenze
ancora una volta però ritorniamo sulle
nostre competenze
una visibilità con la consapevolezza che
non avevamo prima cresciamo no ad ogni
giro
come vedete c'è l'asse che va da
competenza contributo che quello del
know how del contributo che dove gli
altri di cui parlavamo anche prima
e poi c'è l'asse delle relazioni della
risonanza che invece quello sulle
persone ogni quadrate e collegato ad una
griglia in cui vado a rispondere a delle
domande molto concrete cioè specifico
guido degli obiettivi specifici
in ognuno dei quadranti vado a definire
delle azioni chiave chi activities dei
capi a e quindi key performance
indicator e dei key learning in ogni
quadrante imparo delle cose che poi
utilizzerò anche sugli altri quadranti
io ho supportato tantissime persone
utilizzando questo strumento persone
molto diverse
molto diverse perché avevano storie
diverse perché avevano un profilo
differente caratteri differenti un
lavoro diverso però tutti erano
accomunati alla fine delle giornate che
facevamo che erano anche molto faticose
e poi anche dunque tutto questo percorso
di evoluzione da una luce una luce una
carica un'energia che derivava
dall'essere andati verso un
miglioramento essere cambiati aver
superato dei limiti che si pensava di
avere essere usciti fuori dalla propria
zona di comfort aver visto il prossimo
passo che volevano fare quando lavoriamo
sul core square
lavoriamo anche utilizzando quest altro
strumento che si chiama personal systems
canvas che vai lavorare sull'identità e
ci porta a focalizzarci a rispondere ad
alcune domande domande come i miei punti
di forza
oppure quali sono i benefici che io
porto heine stakeholder oppure quali
sono i crash nspaces in cui io devo
agire che il space qui nella chiave di
john ag e quindi quei momenti e quei
luoghi in cui scorrono flussi conoscenza
dove trovo le persone le risorse per
migliorare perché l'identità l'identità
perché quando so chi sono
so anche dove voglio andare
è qualcosa con cui non nasciamo è
qualcosa che evolviamo vivendo e si basa
ed è influenzata dalle nostre scelte da
quello che decidiamo di fare dalle
nostre azioni
dalle nostre dalle nostre aspirazioni
dei nostri obiettivi è influenzata
fortemente dalle nostre esperienze
soprattutto quelle esperienze che io
definisco
firenze trasformative sono quelle
esperienze che definiscono un prima e un
dopo
ognuno di voi se parliamo dispense
trasformative penserà a cose diverse
penserà al corso di yoga che mi ha
insegnato a respirare penserà al corso
di apnea che mi ha insegnato a svuotare
la mente non lo so io quando penso a
esperienze trasformativa e soprattutto
pensa viaggi queste cuba io sono tornata
da cuba cambiata
a parte insomma potrei raccontarvi tanti
aneddoti però quello che più di tutto ho
imparato è stato a non dare nulla per
scontato
la normalità o la normalità che io penso
che ci sia e la mia normalità non è la
normalità di tutti se io vado in giro e
penso di collegarmi col mio smartphone
internet eccetera qualunque sito che
voglia bene non è così in tutto il mondo
però quando tocchi con mano ti rimane
impressa c cavolo non devo dare nulla
per scontato alta esperienza
trasformativa mio figlio cinque mesi fa
sono diventata mamma
e stata un'esperienza che mi ha cambiato
tanto leo mi sta insegnando ogni giorno
cose diverse
forse la cosa che mi ha insegnato di più
e la gratitudine
quello che io imparo nella mia vita
personale lo porto nel mio lavoro lo
porto dei miei clienti
e allora perché non pensare che quello
che imparo sul lavoro lo porto lo posso
portare anche nella mia vita personale
sono due sfere che si nutrono l'un
l'altro non sono delle sfere separate il
lavoro possono iniziare a vederlo come
uno spazio in cui sperimentare uno
spazio veramente per crescere lì o delle
risorse o delle sfide o delle persone e
allora perché non iniziare a vederlo in
questo modo proprio sul lavoro io ho
imparato una cosa che poi mi ha cambiato
tantissimo
questo è il il training della
di lego sirius play una metodologia che
usiamo tantissimo e dove ho preso la
certificazione sono diventata un
facilitatore certificato in questa
metodologia quello che ho imparato è
stato che il sapere della parte
emozionale è importante tanto quanto
quello razionale che quello che sento
sui temi è importante tanto quanto
quello che penso
questo mi ha portato a catena a cambiare
tantissime cose e questo training fa
parte nel mio lavoro non sembra magari
perché ci sono in nero in mattoncini ma
è così fidatevi una metodologia tra
l'altro potentissima sto cambiando di un
cambio di prospettiva di vedere le cose
in un modo diverso di vedere il mio
lavoro in un modo diverso se inizierò a
farlo magari inizierò a fare alcune cose
in un in un'altra chiave e non farò più
alcune azioni o ne farò di nuove oppure
parole stesse identiche cose ma in un
modo diverso quando lo riconosciamo
negli altri questo questo modo di vivere
il proprio lavoro
lo vediamo subito e brillano se davvero
ci crediamo possiamo iniziare ad avere
un impatto sul nostro ecosistema
nutrirlo farle evolvere se iniziamo a
farlo come un virus impiccheremo le
persone intorno a noi
e allora il tutto il cambiamento che
riusciremo a determinare sarà più delle
singole parti
gibran dice il lavoro è l'amore reso
visibile una frase secondo me è
meravigliosa io ci credo davvero questa
cosa il punto è iniziare a vivere il
nostro lavoro
in questa chiave e lo è davvero saremo
portatori in cambiamento nel nostro
ecosistema in noi e anche fuori di noi
grazie
[Applauso]